it never occurred to Ayman al-hassan
that a small demonstration in the old
quarter of Damascus 12 years ago would
change his country and his destiny
[Music]
originally from the Northwestern city of
maharatan Norman he and his family are
always on the Move seeking shelter from
government shelling and air strikes by
Russian planes
we are the ones who pay the price
displacement shelling add to this the
earthquake we are helpless and we suffer
across towns and Villages under Rebel
control in Northwestern Syria people
face a tough reality
Bashar al-assad remains in power
backed by Iran and Russia he is now
hoping to reconcile with the countries
that once sought to topple him
Ahmed was 14 when the uprising started
he survived battle bombs as rights and
earthquakes
he says acceptance of the Assad regime
is a betrayal of the people who died in
the uprising well actually this idea of
the reconciliation with the sad regime
is ridiculous and is completely rejected
by the people here in Northwest Syria
the Assad regime and it's Allah Russia
and Iran have been killing those people
for over 11 or 12 years how can we are
counsel with with him
a truce brokered by Russia and Turkey in
March 2020 still holds but Rebel forces
led by the powerful group
remain defiant
we have restructured and reorganized our
forces they are modernized better
equipped we've also Consolidated our
defense lines and if our enemies decide
to cross those lines they will pay a
hefty price
for now the conflict seems endless the
International Community has accused
Assad of laying Siege to towns starving
people and using chemical weapons
but at the same time it's never fully
trusted the rebels a few months into the
uprising Syrian rebels were advancing to
capture Damascus
but their military games were soon
reversed when Assad and his allies went
on the offensive
now the rebels have retreated to their
last stronghold in idli Province
outgunned and outnumbered their future
hangs by a threat